[Music]
hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
this is Casey Spivey hey Casey Spivey
from Screen Rant she puts up a couple
videos a day over at Screen Rant you can
follow her at Twitter and Instagram
hey underscore case so this video was
requested and Casey actually knows this
guy Greg's got talent school they don't
they always say match third party
content whenever you use one other
videos but they usually let you keep
them up they let us keep them up so
that's all that counts
so just for you guys Casey knows this
guy preacher Lawson is a comedian and he
recalls a weird run-in with a stranger
America's Got Talent the finals just
happened okay right yeah I think he was
last two or something like that he's
your friend who's popular oh yeah he is
now he was famous all right I know you
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow hey do you not like you how is it -
it feels like the finals
[Laughter]
save me with the end joke you did
[Music]
[Applause]
everyone gave a standing ovation see
everyone give a standing ovation except
for Heidi Oh Heidi but Heidi was into as
others I've watched his other ones that
they put up there pretty good - can't
believe she didn't stand come on Heidi
broken ankle or something yeah geez
Heidi huh that was awesome
it's crazy to go on something like
America's Got Talent and go I do comedy
singing and crazy magic tricks and all
these I mean he's been doing this for
like I think 7 years or something
Wow yeah he did that bit at my show oh
really
you ever date him no he has a girlfriend
that is gorgeous and great
that's too bad you could be riding the
high life right now could be I could be
I do be famous too Jason
mmm and Jason and Jason Jason yes I know
what that was
I could be also famous yeah I could be
almost famous yes okay I go to the Comi
store often and I yeah flappers
Shaquille oh I don't like perform well
we should go yeah I just go for the
drinks $10 or Friday are perfectly soggy
enough oh dude yeah they're amazing I
watched a lot of like these Netflix
specials stand-ups I notice the number
one thing is comics tend to be more
vulgar sexual is where a lot I feel like
it audiences have sort of grown used to
that because we find that as being real
and more relatable when we hear it like
I was listening to Jerry Seinfeld's
latest one on Netflix and I was like
this is such clean humor and it's kind
of weird so clean this is for the most
part clean humor yeah I didn't realize
it was clean humor though until the last
video or something like that somebody
called it out I was like I didn't
realize right I don't think he curses at
all I mean he can't for America's Got
Talent but I don't remember him Percy
like in this point is actual material
outside of writer this is actual
material so there's like no you know
something to point like a naked guy it's
like that's the most sexual against guys
naked but he doesn't like talk about it
as wing and dangling man you know that's
the proper word which is that Jason to a
pennis so you want to make a joke like
that so that's even more challenging I
think to go on a show like this and
you're like man you gotta be super to
clean and still make the crowd laugh and
they get to the finals that is
incredibly inappropriate that's probably
why he was able to get so far is because
he's done seven years of clean College
fascinating it's like I don't really
hear many clean comics like I went to a
flapper show recently in every comment
sex jokes vulgarity swear words okay and
then some guy came up on stage of the
introduces the winner of clean comedy
stand-up or like he like won some like
contest the thing and no one laughed at
any of his jokes um it's like I feel
like we're used to that as a medium
right it's like more edgy real so that's
that's incredibly impressive that he was
able to do that that bit what he's like
spazzing out yeah it's all for the
punchline to end the joke that's
brilliant really
because you are I'm in the audience like
this is funny it's kind of going on a
little bit too long come on
but that joke really saves it at the end
Heidi you should have stood what do you
have you said you go even if you don't
love it come on man it's guys when I'm
on stage telling jokes give him a break
she probably wanted the kid to win races
did he win I don't know what happened
no the the kid won the ratio of course I
should have pay attention I think so
that's what I mean that's that's so
impressed that as a stand-up comic you
really get that fall now when you're
going against like crazy things that
people do yeah but there you be a puppet
right now children children
yeah guys can do things how can you beat
it I mean you can be sure he shouldn't
be chilly you shouldn't everybody really
he just he was honoring yeah it's legal
never be never be children he's a good
guy clean Iman you know anyway subscribe
to the real rejects click that
notification bell hey case hey
underscore case Twitter and Instagram
it's Casey's viber damn it this is Casey
Spivey peer on Instagram Twitter right
and part of screen rent that go follow
her there she's an awesome gal Texan GI
Jeff Bridges not cuz he's a clean comic
Jeff Bridges wait no I don't think she
knows Jeff Bruce you know like a name of
a ventriloquist there is one there he
has a special on Netflix right now I I
blink on his name will follow her mr.
Gavin sweater Hey